take a highly-trained teacher I need
someone to read these two thinking
questions for me
laptops loaded with education software
and 36 students rotating through three
activities and you have a new way to
teach kids it's called blended learning
and here at Alliance Smith Tech High
School in Los Angeles
Veronica Bane uses it to introduce for
ninth graders to Romeo and Juliet what
did Romeo do what is he referring to in
her classroom students are divided into
groups of 12 it's hard to adapt to a
class of 36 but to a class or a station
of 12 it's very easy so who steps in to
fight instead a student can get the same
information three different ways well
she teaches a lesson
how did Thibault kill Mercutio another
Greek uses their laptops for
collaborative work now are you working
independently right now are you supposed
to be working together collaboratively
of us others work independently using
software that adapts to their reading
level one second you better and start a
cellar eating more and the articles get
bigger you start going into bigger
grades and articles are more complex now
and the questions are more complex and
they really have to become a better
reader
what does blended learning allow you to
do in a classroom that you couldn't do
before with this model it forces you as
a teacher to structure your classroom in
such a way that no kid falls by the
wayside technology also helps keep these
digital natives on the right track
I am wondering about a couple things
principal Lori Rhodes uses remote
desktop to keep an eye on her students
let's say I go into mr. Ramirez class
and Here Come all of his screens yeah
exactly so I would say the exact same
thing it said maybe it's science it's
true and this is a Spanish class however
and this person is watching insects
versus arachnids I can click on that and
I can send a message and I can say are
you supposed to be watching this video
and it says from dr. Rhodes and then
let's say up see they change their
screen the staff here believes using the
best of traditional teaching and
technology will develop skills critical
to future success what we're seeing is
kids who can communicate quickly who can
get data quickly who can differentiate
for themselves or expect their teachers
to do so not what we had as kids